conquistadors once wrote of an enormous
rack of skulls called azam partly in the
16th century Aztec city of Tenochtitlan
a row of vertical posts connected by
cross beams threaded with human skulls
flanked on each side by towers of skulls
and mortar the mashita the founders of
Tenochtitlan and one cultural group that
comprised the Aztecs thought human
sacrifices would feed the gods and
ensure the continued existence of the
world for the conquistadors the skulls
evinced the musci cos barbarism and
justified their conquest of the city in
1521 they tore down the templo mayor and
that's on partly in front of it paving
over the ruins and building what would
become Mexico City as the centuries
passed historians began to wonder the so
fondly had ever existed at all in 2015
researchers discovered a site that would
remove any doubts about the somepony's
existence when they excavated the
remains of the rack and one of the
towers underneath a colonial period
housed on the street just north of
Mexico City's Cathedral the team dug
about 20 testbeds
an earthing modern debris colonial
porcelain and finally the basalt slabs
of a mushy capir ëadd floor as they dug
hundreds of skull fragments began to
appear but they weren't sure that's what
they were seeing until they found the
post holes the size and spacing of the
holes allowed them to estimate the
Szombathely size it turned out to be an
incredibly imposing rectangular
structure 35 metres long about 14 meters
wide and an estimated 4 to 5 meters tall
they also discovered one of the towers
made of skulls and mortar over two
seasons of excavations archaeologists
carefully collected a sample of a
hundred and eighty skulls from the tower
as well as thousands of skull fragments
hoping to learn more about mushiya
rituals will post-mortem treatment of
the body's human sacrifice and even some
families were relatively common in many
Mesoamerican cultures
cut marks on the skulls leave no doubt
they were defleshed after death and the
decapitation technique seemed quite
clean and uniform in earlier studies
analysis of the teeth and bones of
skulls on earth and templo mayor
suggested that most of the victims were
born in various regions of Mesoamerica
but that many had spent significant time
in Tenochtitlan before their deaths some
historical accounts report cases of
captive warriors living with the
families of their captors for months or
years before they were sacrificed it's
details like these that have
archaeologists excited opening the door
to possible studies ranging from
detailed examinations of sacrificial
rituals to the genetic diversity and
population diversity of Postclassic
Mesoamerica studying these skulls in
such intimate detail helps to tell not
only the individual story of each victim
offered up to the gods but also that of
the Aztec communities themselves
[Music]
you
[Music]